welcome to another episode now today
we'll be programming a brand new out of
thebox key fob purchased off Amazon for
15 bucks and the scan tool required to
make it all
work so what I'm going to do is record
the screen this scan tool is
unbelievable it's really a dealer level
scan tool at a DIY price and I uploaded
a video last week on this scan tool if
you want to check it out so not only can
we program a key fob this vehicle is 19
years old 19 and you may think wow
that's pretty darn old why do you need
this well we need it in this case on the
CTSV but you can also do many other
functions if you want to program your
ECU for whatever the reason if you want
to do bir directional control what that
means is if you want to activate any ABS
at any wheel you want to check the
cooling fans you want to check your door
locks you want to check why you you
don't have a light coming on or turning
off on the dash you can do Limitless
things with this and $330 I know it's a
lot of money but for $330 using it twice
you got your money back you really do so
system
selection and every vehicle is this is
going to read a little bit differently I
tried this off camera just to find the
right function and in this case it is
remote function actuation
now regarding how much this will cost
without a scan tool the local special
functions the local locksmith charges
$150 so if this is your only thing that
you'll ever do pay the 150 but if you're
a
diyer you need this you really really do
the dealership interestingly
enough program key fobs he said that the
cost starts at $2.99 now what does that
mean I don't know is is this vehicle
$299 or is it
$4.99 I don't know so of course you're
better off at the uh locksmith so okay
let's rock and roll here so in this case
I just want to do one
key now it just unlocked all the doors
so we're going to press and hold the
lock and
unlock now okay here we go
okay now this cycled lock and
unlock after a few seconds and it's
still it's saying just hold it and I'm
just holding these buttons anyway just
in case so I don't know once it Cycles
usually that's it you're done but just
in case I'm just holding on that's why
you see the timer going up to close to 7
minutes it's like anything else with
with these tools you sort of have to use
them a couple times to figure everything
out but a few more seconds and we'll see
how we turn
out Yes program
successful let's
see it works lock
unlock perfect let's try the
trunk amazing absolutely amazing like I
said in the previous video I will have a
playlist or I do have a playlist that
you will find below so this will now be
the second video for this scan tool and
over time I'll keep adding videos which
just to give you one more idea because
this recently came up you know these old
GM products man it's just the build
quality is not the greatest when I first
turn on the vehicle what I first thought
so at first I thought a CD was stuck
here it just sounded like the radio was
attempting to read a disc but it's
really this guy right here and what's
happening let me see if I can get this
on camera for you you
guys now as you can see there's no CD in
here so I quickly jumped over to the
scan tool just like before an auto
search and the scan tool picked up the
fault code so not only can you record
the screen you can take
screenshots and I took a screenshot of
of the issue airflow position command so
in other words the diverter that's what
it sounds like to me so in other words
do you want the air to come out through
the front vent your legs the defroster
that's having an issue and because this
is by directional the next step for me
is to start commanding the diverter and
pinpoint where the problem is so it just
goes to show you and not only can you
program a key fob you can do Limitless
things things with this scan tool as
always I hope this was helpful and thank
you for watching